Bien, pues damos por comienzo
la aventura mensual de diciembre de 2025
estamos haciendo récord de gente conectada
nunca habíamos tenido más de 150, creo, creo
una aventura mensual de más de 150 personas
esto me estáis diciendo que el tema
os pica bastante, el tema que traigo hoy
así que bueno, también
hemos invitado esta vez
a la última edición que ya empezó hace un tiempecito
que es la edición 6 de 2025
están por primera vez aquí con nosotros
un mensaje para vosotros que yo os lo he dicho
y siempre repito a los nuevos invitadores a estas sesiones
esto es una sesión donde se habla de cosas muy avanzadas
a veces algunas aventuras mensuales serán
cosas más avanzadas, otras no tan avanzadas
pero siempre son conceptos
o sea, yo siempre damos por sentado
de que todo el mundo que debe de entender al 100%
los conceptos que os explican en esta sesión
es gente que ya ha terminado el programa de mentorías
tanto aquí ahora mismo tenemos dos ediciones
de las cuales no habéis terminado aún
el programa de mentorías
si queréis poner la oreja, ponedla
esta sesión no es obligatoria
como siempre os invito
pero no os agobiéis si no os enteráis de nada
de lo que estamos hablando aquí
y además yo también estoy hablando de historias o temas
que ya en un momento a lo mejor nuestra mentoría mensual
expliqué o hice una introducción
y como es en este caso de esta sesión
voy a dar una actualización sobre un reto
o más que reto un trabajo que hemos hecho
internamente
en este caso Iván
que es un ex alumno
y yo mismo
para poder tener un sistema
de pasar evaluaciones de fondeo
de forma más automática
y que realmente
todo este trabajo que estamos haciendo
y dinero y tiempo
que estamos invirtiendo
pues esto resultará
en un pequeño módulo
de evaluaciones de fondeo
de la mejor forma posible
que nosotros
basados
en experimentos
y en cosas que hemos hecho
y no en teorías
las teorías
yo os las expliqué en verano
pero hoy ya vengo con datos
¿de acuerdo?
con datos
con aprendizaje sobre todo
que esto es lo más interesante
y con un poco
una dirección clara
que creo que
empezaremos a coger
a partir de ahora
que ya estamos adaptando
en diciembre
¿vale?
tanto Iván como yo
luego hay otra parte
de la mentoría mensual
que es
un poco
hacia donde quiero llevar
ciertos expertos advisors
que se están
que estamos dando
desde la marca HobbyCode
incluso también
expertos advisors
que están desarrollando
incluso alumnos actuales
de esta comunidad
por tanto
quiero dar un poco
más de boda a eso
también explicándoos
un expertos advisors
que voy a sacar nuevo
para
para dentro de muy poco
y que os voy a hacer
una demo hoy
¿vale?
que es referente
a un expertos advisors
de copy trading
estos son los dos temas
que quiero afrontar hoy
lo primero que voy a
atacar
es el tema
de las evaluaciones
bueno
y cerrando un poco
la bienvenida
a estas nuevas personas
que están aquí
con nosotros
en una mentoría mensual
lo dicho
sin agobios
poned la oreja
pillad lo que queráis
pillar
pero
pero no os agobéis
y no os enteráis
de algunas cosas
porque
vuestro foco es
el programa de mentorías
¿vale?
hasta que lo terminéis
esto se subirá
también grabado
en Homeward
de hecho
los que sois nuevos
la edición 6
de este año
vais a tener acceso
ahora cuando subamos
esta sesión
cuando la subamos
en Homeward
vais a tener acceso
se os van a habilitar
ya todas las
mentorías mensuales
históricas
que hemos tenido
desde que estamos
en Homeward
¿de acuerdo?
tanto no solo esta
sino también se os van a habilitar
las anteriores
sugerencias
pasáis de ella
hasta el mes
número 5
hasta que terminéis
el programa de mentorías
¿vale?
si la miráis
es responsabilidad
de cada uno
vale pues
dicho esto
voy a ir al tema
¿vale?
he preparado
unas 10 expositivas
para explicarles
un poco
el tema
de
este tema
¿vale?
así que lo tengo
por aquí
voy a presentar
pantalla
a partir de ahora
estaba todo el mundo
aceptando a la gente
que iba entrando
a partir de ahora
te tendré un ojo
como siempre
pero
me tendréis que dar
un espacio de tiempo
para que lo acepte
si vais saliendo
ostras
como se nota
que el tema
me gusta
vale
bien
esto aquí
vale
el tema
principal
de la mentoría
de hoy
es una actualización
y explicaros
un poco
el aprendizaje
que llevamos
desde verano
desde finales
de julio
intentando
bueno
os voy a silenciar
a todos
que algunos
aún están ahí
con el micro
que llevamos
desde verano
o sea
para hacer un poco
recap
para que no se acuerda
o para poner un poco
en preámbulo también
la gente
que la primera vez
que está por aquí
desde verano
pues me
bueno
este año
me hice
un propósito
y dije
oye
una de las patas
que no estoy cubriendo
en nuestro programa
de mentorías
que hablo mucho
yo en redes sociales
sobre evaluaciones
de fondeo
que paso una
como lo hago
y tal
pero
hasta cierto punto
yo lo hacía
todo el rato manual
yo las evaluaciones
siempre repasaba manual
de hacer la inversa
en una cuenta
y otra
claro yo
con el potencial
que tenemos
con los resultados
que estamos teniendo
en cuentas
gestionadas
fondeadas
en darwinets
en todos estos sitios
me faltaba
cerrar esa pata
de cómo podemos
usar robots
qué tipo de robots
podemos usar
para pasar
realmente
evaluaciones
de fondeo
porque
es muy distinto
cómo afrontarías
una fondeada
con una evaluación
por tanto
ahí
le dimos bastante
el coco
desde el principio
de año
y este verano
pusimos un plan
en marcha
que era
con
con una metodología
mucho más sencilla
crear robots
que estén pensados
para pasar
evaluaciones
únicamente
de usar y tirar
robots
para ello
desarrollé
la herramienta
de gestión
de escalado
que en mentorías
mensuales
anteriores
ya he dado
tutoriales
cómo se usa
y demás
y que en un futuro
módulo
que va a salir
próximamente
en el primer
trimestre
de 2026
también la voy a
explicar
en clases
de escaladas
la idea
de esta gestión
de escalado
es poder
convertir
los robots
básicamente
cambiar
en la gestión
de riesgo
es decir
stop loss
take profit
de los robots
que queréis
exactamente igual
pero
si llevo
una operación
perdida
quiero arriesgar
mal en la siguiente
para recuperar
esa pérdida
y poder llegar
a nuestro TP
lo más posible
o si tenemos
una racha negativa
seguida
perdiendo
nos va a fundir
antes la buena
pero bueno
es el riesgo
beneficio
que estamos dispuestos
a asumir
en los exámenes
¿vale?
el target
es aumentar
el 33%
de pasar
o sea
ahora mismo
haciendo lo manual
yo os presenté
os enseñé
que aproximadamente
tengo un ratio
del 33%
de pasar
es decir
de cada 3 cuentas
entre el 25
y el 33
para seros sinceros
de cada 3 cuentas
o 4 cuentas
evaluaciones
perdona
que compro
paso una
está muy bien
o sea
tú juegas con esos ratios
y al final
puedes ganar
puedes ser rentable
en cuentas de fondeo
y tener un buen beneficio
para tu bolsillo
¿vale?
todo esto está explicado
empezamos el reto
en verano
todas nuestras ideas
tanto de Iván
y las mías
las pusimos en conjunto
lo materializamos
Iván de hecho
lo materializo
el que ha hecho todo
construir los robots
que hablábamos
y demás
construir sistemas
súper diversificados
en diferentes cuentas
en diferentes activos
en temporalidades bajas
porque al final
eran robots
de usar y tirar
por tanto
temporalidades bajas
los utilizamos
en 2-3
durante un mes
en todas las evaluaciones
y a crear otro
tenemos un sistema
que nos escupa
constantemente
robots únicamente
para evaluaciones
esta es la idea inicial
¿vale?
por tanto
sabiendo ya
conociendo la idea inicial
os voy a presentar
la actualización
de los números
que ya os digo
que obviamente
los números
ha habido muchos errores
entre medias
es decir
los números
los errores
ensucian
esos números
y hemos cambiado
de rumbo
dos veces
¿vale?
si cambiamos de rumbo
porque no hemos visto
cosas que nos gustaban
¿vale?
por tanto
los números
no son
los números que veréis
los que esperáis
son malos
pero veréis
a dónde hemos terminado
veréis
no os quiero dar
más información
ahora lo veréis
a medida que vaya pasando
las diapositivas
¿vale?
hemos pasado
por tres etapas
desde finales
de julio
agosto
que empezamos
seriamente con esto
en la cual
la primera etapa
es una etapa
que os he explicado
que es
porfolios independientes
es decir
nosotros queríamos
lo que yo quería era
tener un porfolio
con diferentes sistemas
que operan
diferentes activos
en temporada de bajas
que sea independiente
¿a qué me refiero
con independiente?
me refiero a que
yo no tenga que hacer
ninguna inversa
operación inversa
en otra cuenta
para asegurarme
ciertos resultados
sino que ese porfolio
con la gestión de escala
es decir
me iban haciendo operaciones
y a medida que
unas ganaban
otras perdían
las que perdían
si había una pérdida
la siguiente
el robot que tocase
me arriesgase más
porque
a la larga
pues eso sería rentable
¿vale?
por aquí me dice Ramón
creo que hay gente
esperando para entrar
no hay nadie
nadie
no tengo nadie
espera
que vuelvan a entrar
si algo lo dice
por los grupos
si tenéis acceso
a los grupos
pues decirle
oye
Ramón no ha dicho
que no
o sea
que vuelvan
a darle al click
¿se ve como Martingala?
no porque la Martingala
aguanta flotantes
aquí no aguantamos
flotantes negativos
¿vale?
Martingala te tocaría
muchísimo antes
los límites diarios
¿vale?
aquí tenemos todos
con Stoblo
lo que toca Stoblo
la siguiente
arriesgamos más
¿vale?
tanto es
porfolios independientes
repito
independientes
es que no depende
de otra cuenta
sino que
queremos ganar
la intención
es ir a ganar
todas las evaluaciones
y que la gestión
de escalado
nos aumente ese ratio
¿por qué?
porque arriesgamos más
en el siguiente trade
como tenemos
estrategias rentables
vamos a terminar
ganando más
del ratio
que teníamos
¿vale?
luego pasamos
por una segunda etapa
esto vimos
que no nos terminó
de funcionar
en la cual
dijimos
vale
vamos a hacer
porfolios
conectados
cuando yo me refiero
es
haciendo inversa
otra cuenta
siguiendo
con la gestión
de escalado
y la etapa
número 3
es
estrategia simple
conectada
¿vale?
no os voy a explicar
más
lo explicaré más
cuando lleguemos
a la fase 3
en la etapa 3
bien
más o menos
cuánto tiempo
hemos ejecutado
estas etapas
etapa 1
que es la que más
yo personalmente
tenía más
esperanzas
hemos estado
casi 3 meses
enteros
con ella
dándole tal
pagando
invirtiendo
en evaluaciones
evaluaciones
es verdad
que he pagado
cierto coste
de errores
técnicos
hemos tenido
en el gesto
de escalado
varios errores
que los hemos ido
detectando
en el momento
que íbamos
al límite
de la gestión
del riesgo
que nos permitían
las empresas
de fondeo
nos fallaban
ciertas evaluaciones
debido al riesgo
máximo
diario
no al
del diario
que eso nunca
debería tocar
pero
por errores técnicos
hemos tocado
algunas de ellas
y seguía
invirtiendo
para tener
unos números
fiables
luego
en la etapa 2
es de 2 meses
en la etapa 3
lo estamos implementando
desde casi
principios
de este mes
vale
cuáles son
los principales
KPIs
que hemos tenido
en esta etapa
luego me podréis
hacer todas las preguntas
que queráis
yo me espero
es decir
el contenido
no es demasiado largo
que os voy a dar
son resultados
y conclusiones
pero me espero
que me hagáis
preguntas
y ahí se demore
más
invirtamos tiempo
en eso
principales KPIs
hemos
no pasado
hemos realizado
31 fases
vale
me refiero
fase 1
fase 2
es decir
una misma cuenta
relación
que hacemos
fase 1
y luego
hacemos fase 2
lo cuento
como 2
2 fases
al final
lo tratamos
como una fase
distinta
de estas 31
fases
han sido
errores nuestros
hemos fallado
por errores técnicos
perdón
técnicos
es decir
ajenos
a nuestra
idea
vale
por eso
yo ya contaba
que había
cierta inversión
que se iba
a ir
a testear
lo que es
la herramienta
de la gestión
de escalado
pasa
lo que pasa
luego cuando
vas a más
más a real
bien
estos son los ratios
que hemos obtenido
esto es de todas
las etapas
en conjunto
de 24
fases
contando
esas 31
bueno
perdón
de esas 31
fases
han sido
fase 1
fase 2
todo esto
contando
con errores
por tanto
hemos tenido
una tasa
esto no es la tasa
de estar
fondeado
esto es una tasa
de pasar
de fase 1
a fase 2
del 29%
pero como que
no es real
es más real
la segunda
esto es descontando
los errores
es decir
tuvimos un error
en fase 2
fijaos
hemos bajado
de 7 a 6
y bastantes errores
en fase 1
de estas 18
fases
hemos llegado
en fase 2
y esto supone
un 33%
de pasar
de fase 1
a fase 2
repito
no es fondeado
vale
de estas 6 fases
¿cuántas evaluaciones
hemos estado
fondeados?
es decir
los números
no son muy buenos
os recuerdo
que estos números
son
de una fase
experimental
no una fase
de digamos
vale
sabemos que esto funciona
vamos a ver el ratio
esto sería la fase posterior
que nos encontramos
ahora
aquí han habido
aprendizajes
hemos cambiado
dos veces
de rumbo
y por tanto
obviamente
pues los números
no son demasiado
elevados
pero aquí
lo que importa
es todos los cambios
que hemos hecho
y los aprendizajes
que hemos obtenido
para subsanarlos
a día de hoy
¿de acuerdo?
etapa 1
ahora os
os separo ya
los
los números
por etapas
porque al final
a lo mejor
las dos fondeadas
han sido al final
¿sabes?
pero no era así
¿vale?
la etapa 1
que es
recordad
porfolio
totalmente independiente
con la gestión
de escalado
que es la primera idea
donde
os presentamos
también
el desarrollo
en Statistic One
del Money Management
KPIs
donde os mostramos
los días de
los días
que tarda de media
en pasar a una fase
de evaluación
que eso era muy top
desarrollado por Iván
esos KPIs
son increíbles
esto proviene
todo de la fase
de la etapa 1
en la etapa 1
hicimos 15 fases
ya aquí
he quitado los errores
porque al final
pues no los cuento
no los tengo en cuenta
de 15 fases
bueno
14 y 6
un 42%
en la etapa 1
es decir
pasábamos
fases 2
íbamos pasando
pero no se materializaban
por A o por B
por cosas del mercado
por cosas del porfolio
por complejidad
que íbamos metiendo
no se materializaban
en fondeada
porque al final
pues solo tuvimos una
en la etapa 2
que fue cortita
fue de
realmente
ahí tuvimos bastantes errores
en la etapa 2
por eso
realmente limpios
había 3 fases
2 fases
en fase 1
y una fase en fase 2
un 50% de pasar
y 0 fondeadas
de esta fase 2
pues no la
no la conseguimos pasar
pero
esto no es representativo
esta etapa 2
porque
ya los aprendizajes
que tuvimos
de la etapa 1
ya nos dimos cuenta
rápidamente
que la etapa 2
no tenía sentido
y os lo explicaré
por qué
la etapa 2
recordad que son porfolios
simplemente
el único cambio
que hicimos
es
en lugar de
tener porfolio independiente
simplemente hacíamos
la inversa
del mismo porfolio
a otra cuenta de fondeo
a otra evaluación de fondeo
¿vale?
pero rápidamente
lo cambiamos
¿por qué?
porque no veíamos
veíamos un problema añadido
incluso
será mejor la etapa 1
que la etapa 2
y nos vamos
en una etapa 3
en la cual
ya llevamos dos fases
sin errores
terminadas
¿vale?
dos fases 1
de las cuales
el 50%
la hemos pasado
que es lo
que nos dice la estadística
que nos dice la etapa 3
y nos dice la etapa 3
porque vamos
con una simple estrategia
a la inversa
¿vale?
que es un poco
volver a los orígenes
y al finalizar
esta pues se ha materializado
pues por casualidad
por cosas de la vida
se ha materializado
esa única fase 2
que hemos conseguido
y es otra
de las fondeadas
que tenemos
estos son números
sacados de dos fases
no son muy representativos
pero ya me cuadra
un poco
con lo que venía
yo haciendo
desde hace años
en las evaluaciones
de fondeo
y que sepas
que actualmente
en esta etapa 3
tenemos ahora mismo
cuatro cuentas activas
¿de acuerdo?
ahora viene
viene lo más importante
de esta sesión
y es donde
entiendo que vendrán
un poco más
las preguntas
y las cosas
y el aprendizaje
lo que es enriquecedor
para vosotros
os voy a explicar
en detalle
lo que hicimos
en cada fase
el objetivo inicial
que teníamos
en cada fase
el por qué
hicimos ese cambio
o en la etapa 1
por qué emprendimos esto
y una vez
terminada esa etapa
los motivos
por el cual
hemos cambiado de etapa
récordas de etapa 1
eran por folios independientes
podíamos tener
un sistema
de
del USD
euro USD
a 5 minutos
junto con una
de la libra llena
a 5 minutos
junto con otro
en
en euro CHF
cosas de estas
¿vale?
mezcladas
4, 5, 6 sistemas
en el mismo porfolio
a 5 minutos
en los cuales
ya sabéis que
la gestión escalada
pues podemos limitar
oye cuando llevemos
3 trades
en el mismo día
no se abre más
y pasamos al día siguiente
¿vale?
es decir
no íbamos a cumplir
todos los trades
que se
que se daban las señales
sino que
cuando llegamos
un cupo ese día
al día siguiente
¿vale?
era un poco así
¿qué es lo que hicimos?
estrategias de M5
¿por qué las hicimos de M5?
porque nosotros necesitábamos
trades cada día
varios trades cada día
cuando
nosotros vamos a trabajar
un porfolio serio
que vamos a poner
en Darwinets
o en Axis Elet
o en cuentas
ya fundeadas
realmente nos da igual
no operar un día
u otro
pues si
trabajamos a H1
pues a lo mejor
de media nos abre
una operación
cada dos o tres días
hay días
que nos abren
dos
o días seguidos
y luego se tira
cuatro o cinco días
sin abrir nada
¿por qué?
porque no va a hacer
la dirección
hacia donde va
esa estrategia
normal
pero nosotros
lo que íbamos a buscar
nosotros no queríamos
estrategias
que a la larga
sean rentables
repito
aquí buscábamos
estrategias
de usar y tirar
un sistema
que nos lo va
escupiendo
cada mes
o cada semana
y que será
M5
para aumentar
el número
de trades
por día
nosotros queríamos
que las fases
se pasasen rápido
no queríamos estar
un mes
con una fase
ni tres semanas
queríamos
que se pase
en cuestión
de entre tres
y diez días
cada fase
¿vale?
creación de
portfolio independientes
creamos cada portfolio
es decir
teníamos
tres evaluaciones
cuatro evaluaciones
en marcha
pues creamos
un portfolio
distinto
para cada evaluación
totalmente independientes
tanto podrían palmar
las cuatro
como podríamos ganar
múltiples activos
como he comentado antes
y además
Iván hizo
un super esfuerzo
de desarrollar
módulos de money management
dentro de Strategic One
que os lo hemos dado
en mentorías anteriores
KPIs
donde repito
podéis ver
incluso los días
que se tarda
en pasar evaluaciones
cada cuando
se pierde una evaluación
esto
muy chulo
o sea
hubo un esfuerzo
en desarrollo
titánico
y
todo esto
lo que implementábamos
con una gestión
escalada
es decir
que a lo mejor
empezábamos arriesgando
el 1%
el 0,8%
de la cuenta
íbamos escalando
íbamos poniendo
un 1.2
de multiplicador
¿qué nos permitía eso?
nos permitía
que a lo mejor
en un mismo día
podríamos abrir
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9
trades distintos
claro
la conjunción
de tantas
estrategias
antes digo
entre 4 y 6
AM5
con un escalado
suave
podíamos perfectamente
tener 6 trades
al día
bien
pero esos trades
aunque los 6
sean positivos
empezamos
con un riesgo
un 0,8
por 6
no es
un 8%
de una fase
es decir
no nos podíamos
pasar una fase
en un día
y ya te digo yo
que la probabilidad
de que
5 estrategias
en diferentes activos
todas 5
AM5
los 5 trades
los 6 trades
que abran
en ese día
la probabilidad
que todos sean
profit
TP
es 0
tendiendo a 0
¿vale?
esto es lo que nos da
la diversificación
es que
obviamente
no todos palmarán
pero tampoco
todos ganarán
en un día
no pegaremos
pelotazos
y esto
hicimos
este objetivo
con el objetivo
de tener sistemas
independientes
tener sistemas
4 o 5
y que tengamos
un custom project
en Statistic One
que vaya escupiendo
esos sistemas
automáticamente
para ir generando
nuestros portfolios
y vayamos poniendo
a medida que vamos
comprando
evaluaciones
el plan era perfecto
¿vale?
y técnicamente
era factible
por lo que teníamos
que probarlo
en real
¿por qué cambiamos
de etapa?
por estos aprendizajes
al final
nosotros necesitamos
resultados
a corto plazo
y cuando juntamos
demasiadas estrategias
juntas
en un mismo portfolio
aunque sean a M5
que a M5
el motivo
de poner M5
era corto plazo
pero juntar
diferentes estrategias
lo que he dicho antes
como que algunas
otras perdían
avanzábamos
muy poco
día tras día
en ese profit
¿vale?
avanzábamos muy poco
repito
tuvimos bastantes
evaluaciones
1 pasadas
de hecho el 33%
se pasaron
de 1 a 2
tuvimos bastantes
el tema era
que tardaban
más de lo debido
nos costaba mucho
a lo mejor
algunas
pues
se alineaban
los rastros
y lo hacían
un poco rápido
en 8 o 10 días
pero la gran mayoría
se iban
a casi un mes
o por ahí
por eso
la primera etapa
son 3 meses
otro punto
era
que teníamos
menor control
de resultados
al tener
sistemas independientes
resultados
no en una operación
en sí
resultados
en cuentas
fondeadas
¿bien?
o evaluaciones
pasadas
fase 1
o fase 2
me refiero
en garantías
entre comillas
¿vale?
es decir
el tener 4
por fuera distinto
en 4 cuentas
aunque vayas
a ganarlas todas
e intentar ganar
todas las batallas
hacían menos
predecible
que yo tuviera
un sistema
que supiera
que al menos
cada 2 semanas
tuviera
una cuenta
fondeadas
a cada
no lo sabíamos
porque nos podía
alargar el tiempo
y 2
podíamos perder
las 4 también
y volver a empezar
y al final
queremos
al final
repito
la idea inicial
es crear un sistema
un sistema
que te escupa
cuentas
fondeadas
¿de acuerdo?
a cierto coste
y no lo cumplía
el aprendizaje
número 3
demasiada dedicación
para el pobre
resultado
esto es importante
porque
mucha gente
no lo
no lo valora
el tiempo que tú
dedicas
por lo que vas a obtener
es decir
mucha gente
en redes sociales
se fija
con el
con el influencer
que pasa cuentas
de fondeo
todo el día
te muestra
evaluaciones
pero no
nunca te muestra
lo que está palmando
el dinero que está palmando
detrás
a lo mejor palma más
de las que te ganan
¿no?
esto ya lo sabemos
que tenemos que hacer
esa diferencia
y tenemos que ser rentables
ahí
pero va un paso
más allá
aquí voy a un paso
es
vale
tengo algo que
puede llegar a ser rentable
puede llegar a funcionar
proporcionalmente
más ingresos
que gastos
pero
la dedicación
que dedico
para ese sistema
que estoy montando
es una variable
que realmente
se transforma
en coste nuestro
en tiempo
no en dinero
sino en tiempo
dedicamos bastante tiempo
en monitorizar
en crear nuevos sistemas
en
no es que tenemos que tener
cuatro porfolios activos
hay que ver
si un porfolio
me ha dejado de funcionar
tener la máquina
que esté creando otro
juntar cada vez
cinco o seis estrategias
de activos distintos
y esto es rápido
esto es rápido
no es
crear un porfolio
no es crear un porfolio
a temporada
de una hora
cuatro horas
y lo pongo
y lo dejo meses trabajando
no no
aquí va
va por días semanas
vale
por tanto
la dedicación
aumenta aquí
y al final
pues
es un tiempo
al final pues
tiempo
dinero
y el punto número cuatro
ir a escalado suave
necesitas realizar
mucho estrés
que ya os lo he avanzado
y tardas demasiado
al final esto no es
no cumplir el objetivo
nosotros lo queremos
en el menor tiempo posible
obviamente
cumpliendo lo que nos piden
las cuentas de fondeo
que son mínimo
tres días de trading
y todas estas cosas
pero no tirarnos
un mes para una fase
de evaluación
sin saber si la vamos a pasar
o no
sin tener garantías
de si al menos una
la vamos a pasar
tanto todo esto
dijimos
vale
lo primero que nos centramos
es
está bien lo que hacemos
porque vamos pasando
a fases dos
al menos
nos falla algo
de materializar
que las fases dos
terminen en fondear
por A o por B
no terminan llegando
creíamos que era
por estadística
pues mira
una racha
de fases dos
que no materializamos
puede ser
porque medianamente
bien para empezar
materializamos bien
pasar fase uno
o fase dos
pero lo que nos faltaba
es rapidez
rapidez
oye
estamos tardando demasiado
en pasar a fase dos
al menos
hay que ir más rápido
luego ya solventaremos
veremos ya
como solventamos
el pasar fase dos
a la fondeada
vale
pues que hicimos aquí
dijimos
dos cosas
bien
el hecho de tardar tanto
sin garantías
vamos a
vamos a crearnos
una garantía
y cuál es la garantía
hacer la inversa
en otra cuenta de fondeo
volvimos a hacer la inversa
por eso puse
por fuera conectada
digo vale
si vamos a tardar tanto
al menos asegurarnos
que una de las dos
la estamos pasando
no que nos
después de estar tanto tiempo
porque repito
el tiempo también es dinero
o coste de oportunidad
al menos que un
que tengamos
una de las dos
si trabajamos con cuatro
dos de las cuatro
pasadas
y la gestión de esclado
que es lo que hicimos
estrategias
M5
bueno
creo que ahí emitimos
algunas de M15
pero más o menos
con el mismo objetivo
vale
es el mismo objetivo
que es que hayan trades
creación de porfolios
seguimos creando
pendientes
aunque ahí los conectamos
múltiples activos
seguíamos haciendo
gestión de escalado
la cambiamos a agresivo
es decir
ya no íbamos a 0.8
ya a lo mejor
ahí vamos
o seguíamos
no perdón
seguíamos yendo
a 0.8
pero
el escalado
lo metíamos
más agresivo
en lugar de permitir
hacer 8 trades
en el día
a lo mejor
solo hacíamos
tres trades
entre todos
y a lo mejor
multiplicamos
por 1.7
1.8
de esta forma
en un segundo trade
y es verdad
aquí buscábamos
porfolios
en la cual buscábamos
que las rachas
sean cortas
que si me viene
una operación ganadora
me venga una ganadora
si me viene una ganadora
me venga otra perdedora
si me viene una perdedora
me venga la ganadora
porque la alternancia
nos iba bien
si metíamos
un multiplicador
muy alto
porque si nos viene
una pérdida
como que sabíamos
que teníamos
muchas probabilidades
de tener una ganancia
posteriormente
íbamos a un multiplicador
elevado
por tanto
nos ganaría dinero
y luego conectamos
el mismo porfolio
con entradas inversas
en otra cuenta
de fonte
¿cuál es el objetivo
con estos dos cambios?
repito
gestión de escalado agresivo
porfolios
a la inversa
tener sistemas dependientes
que pase evaluaciones
con alta tasa de éxito
me refiero a
aquí debería haber puesto
con cierta garantía
para que al menos
si invertimos
todo ese tiempo
al menos nos garantice
que uno de los dos
me pase
que es la verdad
que es el segundo
aumentar la garantía
de tener exámenes pasados
en un cierto tiempo determinado
claro
lo de alta tasa de éxito
y lo de reducir el tiempo
viene dado
a que aumentábamos
el riesgo
porque recuperábamos
más rápido
por tanto
necesitábamos
menos trades
para llegar al
take profit
también necesitábamos
menos trades
para fundirla
obviamente
pero también
para llegar al
take profit
es lo que necesitamos
que haya rapidez
¿vale?
rapidez y cierta garantía
son los dos objetivos
que queríamos
en esta fase
¿cuál es el aprendizaje
que lo vimos
bastante rápido
que mezclar
estas dos cosas
no eran compatibles
una gestión
de escala agresiva
donde el multiplicador
sea alto
con operaciones inversas
no es compatible
y es muy sencillo
de entender
dos cuentas de 100.000
evaluaciones de 100.000
en una ganas 500
el primer trade
una ganas 500
el otro pierdes 500
¿vale?
¿ahora qué hace
el que está perdiendo?
multiplica por 1.8
el siguiente trade
está arriesgado
800 dólares
está ganado
la de aquí
ha ganado
500 dólares
si ahora esta pierde
que arriesga 500 dólares
porque no ha tenido
una pérdida
en esta cuenta
no ha tenido una pérdida
esta se pone a 100
y esta se pone a más 300
de puta madre
¿vale?
si van alternándose
está bien
porque al final
vas terminando ganando
pero hay otras ramas
cuando empiezan a ver
esta gana
y esta pierde
esta habrá perdido
menos 500
menos 800
estaríamos en
menos 1300
y esta estaría
solo a 1000
más 1000
ahí perdemos
hemos perdido
más de lo que
de lo ganado
por tanto
no era tan compatible
el riesgo
elevado
con la inversa
concluimos
que de las dos cosas
hacer la operación
inversa
es lo que siempre
sigue funcionando
y
eso sí
una de las cosas
que hicimos es
aumentar el riesgo
¿vale?
el escalado
no pero aumentar
el riesgo
sobre todo
inicial
de la primera operación
esto sí
que estaba
comprobado
que acortaba
considerablemente
el tiempo
de vida
de una evaluación
ya sea terminando
en T-Profit
o en Stop Loss
¿de acuerdo?
¿por tanto
¿qué hicimos?
vale
aquí lo importante
es ir
a fuego
desde el inicio
muy a fuego
y hacer operaciones
inversas
por tanto
aquí
y esto es
un poco
ejercicio
que yo tuve que hacer
interior mío
tuve que tirar
recular hacia atrás
dejar de lado
todo el tinglado
de porfolios
de gestión de escalado
todo lo que habíamos montado
al final
pues llegar a un punto
que cuando experimentas
y lo ves en real
pues tienes que tomar decisiones
y decir
oye
pues a lo mejor
todo este grueso
que hemos hecho
no ha servido
ha servido
para darme cuenta
de esto otro
¿vale?
lo hemos apartado
lo hemos simplificado
todo muchísimo
y ahora
estamos en la fase
en la etapa 3
que es una estrategia simple
¿quiere ver lo simple que es?
y conectada con la inversa
creación de una estrategia
muy simple
en el wizard
y por qué digo
es por qué no utilizar
el builder
la búsqueda
porque esto
os lo digo a vosotros
o sea
al final
vuelvo un poco
a lo que yo hacía
antes de forma manual
que era
entrar
yo antes lo hacía
entrada
aleatoria
euro dólar
compra-venta
en dos proveedores distintos
y esto lo repetía
hasta que uno me llegaba
al take profit
y luego
el otro me llegaba
a perder la cuenta
y iba
al límite diario
al límite que podía abrir
en una misma idea
o el día
¿vale?
por tanto
en una perderé
y en otra ganaré
exactamente lo mismo
voy a perder comisiones
en ambas
eso sí
si por casualidad
con catenas
muchas alternadas
vas a palmar
bastante en comisiones
pero bueno
como que muchas empresas
o algunas empresas
se han puesto
muy tiquismiquis
de las entradas
aleatorias
¿vale?
porque según ellos
consideran
o te pueden tirar atrás
una evaluación
si tú haces de gambler
es decir
abres sin ver el gráfico
abres una
una orden en compra
sin seguir un patrón
y eso al final
lo dictan ellos
luego ¿no?
tanto ellos te pueden saltar
y decir
oye
no estás siguiendo
una idea de trading
una regla de trading
estás siguiendo gambler
te quitamos la evaluación
si vosotros
anteriormente diseñáis
cualquier chorrada
de estrategia
en algo bizar
por ejemplo
un cruce de medias
a esta empresa
le podéis ir a decir
no no
fíjate
yo entro
cuando el cruce
de la media
de 20 periodos
con la de 60
se cruzan
yo entro
no te lo demuestro
pam pam pam pam
y ahí si te la quitan
pues ya es solo una empresa
pues que te van a robar
y ya está
pero al menos tienes
algo con los cuales
poderle decir
oye no no
yo sigo esta estrategia
encima la tengo automatizada
toma
¿sabes?
ahí nos salvamos en eso
un solo activo
fíjate que estoy volviendo
regulando
a todo gas
y que hayan
un activo
pero que hayan
trades cada día
es decir
la estrategia
tiene que generar
trades cada día
porque a nosotros
lo que nos interesa
es la entrada
realmente
de verdad
nos da igual
en las evaluaciones
si la estrategia
es rentable o no
fijaros que no he puesto
estrategia rentable
es una estrategia
que le puedes explicar
y tenga sentido
y que te genere
que estrategias
pueden generar
cada día
entradas
pues os vais
a la temporada
desde 30 minutos
15 minutos
5 minutos
y hacer un simple
cruce de medias
podéis hacer
cuando el RSI
se vaya a 30
o a 70
podéis hacer
cuando el MACD
se cruce
podéis hacer
mil historias
podéis entrar
cuando supero
un máximo anterior
un mínimo anterior
al revés
da igual
la que se os ocurra
o veáis
en internet
más sencilla
de todas
que veáis
la automatización
es en algo wizard
que es sencillo
y tenéis al menos
el robot ahí
¿vale?
¿por qué en algo wizard?
porque de esta forma
nos permite exportar
en robot
y en robot
sacado del código
de strategy one
que nos irá bien
para pasarla
por el gestor
de escalado
¿por qué hay que pasarla
por el gestor de escalado?
porque al menos
es verdad que
te posibilita
todo lo que hacíamos
anteriormente
pero ponerles
el multiplicador
a uno
que no multiplique
oye
esto es
repito
quiero hacer un parón
esto es
experiencia propia
con Iván
luego cada uno
a lo mejor
habrá gente
que habrá hecho
maravillas
con la gestión de escalado
pero
al menos
ahí te habilita
al poder
tener un trade
que te abra
a la inversa
¿vale?
no solo
es la gestión de escalado
quien te permite
abrir trades
a la inversa
esto es para poner
un expert advisor
en otro sitio
sino que hoy
también os quiero mostrar
un expert advisor
que hemos desarrollado
que es un copy trader
¿vale?
también podría utilizar
ambas cosas
¿de acuerdo?
pero lo interesante
es que puedes abrir
la inversa
bueno
copy trader
no abre la inversa
perdona
no
sería con la gestión
de escalado
y punto número 4
riesgo alto por trade
si por ejemplo
una empresa de fondeo
como máximo
os dejan arriesgar al día
un 5%
y tal 4
o al 4 y medio
dejad un espacio
por si hay slipage
por si justamente
entra
en un momento
de alta volatilidad
yo diría un 4
4,2
no más
hay empresas
que esto también
nos hemos visto
que nos han fusilado
por
porque nos han arriesgado
más
por ejemplo
creo que era
Wall Street Funded
que hay
sí ¿no?
Wall Street Funded
es decir
es verdad
que solo te dejan
arriesgar
un 5% al día
pero
hay una norma
que dice
idea de trade
y eso también se ha puesto
mucho en la idea
de trade
por eso es importante
que hay una estrategia
lógica detrás
aunque no sea rentable
por cada idea
de trade
solo te dejan
arriesgar
un 3%
algo así
claro
esto significa que
en una misma entrada
en un mismo trade
no puedes arriesgar
más del 3%
tienes que esperar
a que el precio
se mueva un poco más
para que sea otra idea
de trade
¿vale?
pronto ahí
pues lo tenéis que ajustar
tenéis que entender
en qué empresas
estáis haciendo trading
y cuáles son los límites
y ajustar eso
al máximo
¿vale?
y
y ya está
¿con qué objetivo?
reducir muchísimo
el esfuerzo
a dedicar
pero muchísimo
y esa estrategia
te va a servir
para todas las evaluaciones
no tienes que ir generando más
puedes inventarte
tres distintas
las tienes
y las tienes
para siempre
¿vale?
simplemente para algún día
decir
oye
detrás hay esta lógica
para automatizar
lo que sabemos
que funciona de verdad
que al final
es un poco
recular un poco
en todas las movidas
que teníamos
en las cabezas
al final
yo creo que
rectificar
también
es de sabios
siempre
al final
es lo que
el objetivo
es que
todo el mundo
tenga más cuentas
fondeadas
y al final
es ir un poco
a automatizar
lo que
yo ya sabía
que estaba funcionando
de antes
obviamente
mejorándolo un poquito
que aquí la mejora
es
repito
en lugar de ir
de forma aleatoria
creamos una estrategia
que no nos cuesta nada
un cruce de media
lo que sea
alguna chorra de estas
y
y volver a la tasa
de fondearte
una de cada
tres
cuatro
sinceramente
yo tenía
esperanzas
y también
le convencí
en cierto modo
a Iván
de que podríamos
llegar
a incluso
tener un ratio
de fondeo
de una entre dos
una entre tres
entre ahí
el ratio
pero es tal
el esfuerzo
que hay que dedicar
y tal
el imax
de que hay que hacer
en ese sentido
que
que no vale la pena
que al final
con tener un ratio
entre uno
tres
cuatro
con cierta
inversión mínima
en cuentas
de fondeo
podéis montar
vuestra estructura
de cuentas
fondeadas
y luego
poner vuestros
portfolios
obviamente
por lo tanto
al final
un poco ejercicio
de evaluar
un poco el esfuerzo
podríamos haber dado
un pelín más
en cada etapa
lo podríamos haber dado
vale la pena
ese esfuerzo
sin saber el resultado
por el
por el mínimo incremento
que íbamos a buscar
pues yo considero
que no vale la pena
y al final
esta etapa tres
creo que es
hiper sencilla
o sea
es
repito
es un poco
tirar un poco
no es tirarlo a la basura
al final
es un poco
pues abandonar un poco
el esfuerzo
que hemos hecho
estos últimos meses
pero porque al final
queremos resultados
no
cosas guapas
ni que vendan mucho
¿no?
tanto yo creo que esto
o creemos que esto
es lo que
nos va a funcionar
a partir de ahora
tenerlo automatizado
tener esos
ES que tengáis vosotros
lo bueno de todo esto
es que cada uno
podrá crear su propia estrategia
no habrá copy trading
de otra forma
tampoco habría copy trading
porque cada uno
se crea sus propios sistemas
pero
de esta forma tampoco
es decir
nos mantenemos
fuera del copy trading
entre nosotros
y automatizamos
algo que
yo personalmente
sé que funciona
porque lo he estado haciendo
durante
durante más de un año
de forma manual
eso sí
en la actualidad
tenemos
con este método
yo te digo
llevamos menos de un mes
con ello
tenemos una fondeada
que rescatamos
de una fase 2
de la anterior fase
pero a cambio
de esa fondeada
hemos quemado una
porque hacemos la inversa
¿vale?
siempre que tenemos una fondeada
tenemos una quemada
y ahora
a día de hoy
tenemos cuatro activas
que
no sé si van
de mano
no apunté
los profits
o los negativos
que llevamos en ellas
pero
están por ahí
¿no?
una creo que está
un menos 3
la otra un más 2
porque
la tomamos
con comisiones
y cosas extras
pero sí
van más o menos
sobre lo previsto
¿vale?
pues y las cuatro
empresas que estamos
trabajando
son las que
ha puesto Iván
creo que ha contestado
uno que ha preguntado
en el chat
The Fiverr
Wall Street Funded
The Trading Pit
y Funded Nets
¿vale?
creo que en todas ellas
hemos pasado fases
creo que sí
en todas ellas
creo que hemos llegado
a pasar fases
por tanto
nadie nos ha puesto
ningún problema
para hacer este tipo
de prácticas
y las dos fondeadas
han estado
en Wall Street Funded
y en Funded Nets
y yo personalmente
he estado
fondeado
en The Fiverr
y en The Trading Pit
o sea
no tenía ningún problema
con ninguna de las cuatro
vale
hasta aquí
el tema
de las evaluaciones
ahora viene el turno
de preguntas
¿de acuerdo?
respondo la primera
que me habéis hecho
en el chat
¿cuántos trades
estáis añadiendo
Ramón?
que haga mínimo
un trade al día
vamos a un trade al día
con estas estrategias
y oye
cuando hagas
una estrategia
por ejemplo
un cruce de medias
obviamente
si lo podéis
a cinco minutos
a la primera hora
del día
os va a entrar
porque siempre
se va a dar uno
no lo pongáis
cuando hay poca volatilidad
yo que sé
poned en estatística
en el Algo Wizard
que opere
de las nueve de la mañana
hasta las ocho de la tarde
donde sepáis
que hay más volatilidad
¿vale?
por alguna razón
no usar
Stimov
a mí porque me banearon
vosotros lo podéis usar
si queréis
Javi dime
¿qué tal Ramón?
¿qué tal a todos?
buenas noches
quiero hacer
dos consultas
yo soy de la nueva
mentoría
de hecho todavía
no la terminé
nos queda un mes
pero ya estaba viendo
algunos de los videos
de las mentorías mensuales
así que
me familiaricé
con todos estos términos
pregunta uno es
si a la hora de hacer
una estrategia
a la inversa
literalmente
les ha sucedido
de que ninguna gana
que se pierdan las dos
porque
que gane una
y que la otra pierda
tiene sentido
pero bueno
habría que ver
si coincide
pero no nos ha pasado
no nos ha pasado
lo que sí puede pasar
es que
justamente
cuando
en una te gane
la otra te pierda
a la siguiente
te haga al revés
la que te ha ganado
te ha perdido
y constantemente
estás subiendo
bajando
subiendo bajando
no vas a llegar
todo el rato
a estar las dos
en 100.000
o igual
vas a partir
desde más abajo
porque las comisiones
te van comiendo
eso es el riesgo
que hay
es el único
es lo único
que te puede pasar
para perder las dos
a lo mejor
deberías hacer
yo qué sé
te diré
53 en cada una
y que las comisiones
te hayan fundido
esto pasa
la probabilidad
de que te pase
eso es muy baja
realmente
pero una cosa
una cosa que sí
que pasaba
con la gestión
de escalado
es que a veces
la señal
se daba
en una cuenta
pero la inversa
no se daba
en la otra
entonces
imagino que esto
con el copy trading
se puede solucionar
pero esto sí
que tuvimos problemas
o sea
sobre todo
en temporalidades bajas
en M5
o M1
puede ser que el cruce
de media
se dé en una
pero como los gráficos
son ligeramente distintos
en la otra
no se dé
y no entre
esto nos había pasado
bien
y la segunda pregunta
es
el concepto
de los tiempos
es una decisión
propia
o sea
es un objetivo
personal
o las cuentas
o estas empresas
te piden un tiempo
determinado
como máximo
perdona
¿cuál es la pregunta?
si el tema
de que el objetivo
de esto que están creando
es hacerlo
en el menor tiempo
posible
es algo propio
de lo que están
intentando hacer
o son condiciones
de estas cuentas
no no
es objetivo nuestro
es que yo
yo considero
que las evaluaciones
se tienen que pasar rápido
o las quemas
o las pasas
ok ok
te explico
lo que yo pienso
luego cada uno
es libre de opinar
y de pensar
y hacer lo que
lo que considere
entiendo
bueno perfecto
eso era
gracias
a ti Javi
voy a contestar
primero en chat
no ponen pegas
por los robots
en fondeo
si por el copy trading
como eres exactamente
el copy trading
realmente
no es
o sea
realmente
lo que ellos llaman
copy trading
es que
tú
uses el mismo robot
que yo
en la misma empresa
de fondeo
eso es copy trading
pero
no que yo
implemente sistemas
de copiar trades
en diferentes cuentas
de otras empresas
de fondeo
que realmente
te lo
realmente
técnicamente
está prohibido
tu poder copiar
trades a la inversa
de una empresa
u otra
pero entre ellas
no se hablan
pero de esto
no lo van a saber
nunca
ni lo podrán
como decir
demostrártelo
lo que está prohibido
es que
tú estés
en una cuenta
en ftmo
yo esté
en otra cuenta
en ftmo
y los dos
usemos
el mismo robot
eso es
esto está prohibido
veo que uno
de los criterios
que podamos
fondear
en un tiempo
corto
tendría sentido
que el factor
tiempo
que sea un sistema
lento
pero cumpla
un rato
de fondeo
superior
claro
lo que dice
es que nadie
te lo garantiza
es que
si tú vas
a un rato
de fondeo
superior
vas a
más trades
bueno
sí
puedes tener
más rate
más
sí
puedes ir
a más
ratio
sí
pero
a mi punto de ver
del negocio
de las cuentas
de fondeo
no tiene sentido
estar meses y meses
en una misma evaluación
no tiene sentido
en mi opinión
porque esto
trata de rotar
el capital
todo el rato
rotar el capital
y es un poco
el desapego
a esa evaluación
christopher
sí
me escucha
ramón
hola
sí
bueno
respecto
al
cuántos
intentos
realizaste
y cuántas
pasaron
christopher
has entrado
desde el inicio
de esta mentoría
no
pues
luego te
te sugiero
que te la veas
vale
sí
y la otra pregunta
es
cómo
hacen la copia
eso no lo entendí
muy bien
cómo hacen la copia
o sea
la inversa
solo poniendo
los robots
en
esto es con
el gestor
de escalado
es una herramienta
sí
lo expliqué
en mentorías
mensuales
pasadas
tú
estás en edición
ahora mismo
no
ya
ya terminé
el curso
vale
pues en
mentorías
mensuales
pasadas
hago un tutorial
de la gestión
de escalado
repásatelo
porque ahí explico
cómo convertir
un robot
y que se añadan
esas opciones
ah ya
pero igualmente
tú tienes que tener
dos metatraders
abiertos
y todo eso
sí
vale
gracias
es
Sergio
me acuerdo
a ver si es
sí
soy yo
Sergio
¿qué tal?
bueno
pues estamos
sí
te quería preguntar
comentas
el hecho
de crear
la estrategia
simple
en algo
guadizar
esto quiere decir
que habéis probado
que el builder
no aumenta
la probabilidad
usando esta
estrategia simple
es decir
no aumenta
la probabilidad
de pasar
la evaluación
así es
porque íbamos
íbamos
a
es decir
si usásemos
estrategias
H1 hacia arriba
que es lo que
utilizamos
para crear
nuestros porfolios
y lo que realmente
creemos que tenemos
hay más fiabilidad
se nos iba
demasiado largo
el tiempo
de una evaluación
por tanto
ese es el objetivo
principal
para mí
a mi punto de ver
es pasarla rápido
tanto ya
sistemas H1
o para arriba
no encajaban en mi plan
nos teníamos que ir
en CFDs
por debajo
de H1
en brokers
que son cuentas
de fondeo
brokers donde te puedes
descargar datos a ti
como puede ser Darwin
si en brokers
de cuentas de fondeo
por lo tanto
no tenemos esos datos
íbamos a crear
sistemas de usar
y tirar
y
claro
¿sí?
entonces
básicamente
que no
no escalan bien
o sea
da igual
la estrategia
que te salga
que es
como hacer
la random
íbamos que
o sea
nos costaba mucho
incrementar ese ratio
pero mucho
mucho esfuerzo
y por tanto
pues decidimos
simplificarlo
saber lo que
funcionaba bien
y
regular un poco
hacia atrás
vale
pues nada está
merci
a ti
me alegro de verte
igualmente
bueno
oíte
ahora me ves
ahora sí
bueno
Sergio es el que
el que también está
en H1Millón
que lo comuniqué
el otro día
en el grupo
así que enhorabuena
de nuevo
gracias
voy a leer dicha
vale
Francis
para
tutorial de gestor
de escalado
mejor miraros
una clase
que hice entera
explicándolo
no se ha cambiado
desde entonces
vale
me sabe mal
porque al final
la mentoría de hoy
es de unos temas
que tenemos
planificados
tratar
vale
que horarios
se manejan
el mismo que Darwinets
los bloques
que utilizamos
todo lo hace
con robots
en automático
nada de manual
como es el proceso
Robert
lo explico
en mentorías
mensuales
antiguas
vale
no sé si
los que me preguntáis
esto
probablemente
seáis de ediciones
actuales
que no habéis visto
las mentorías
mensuales
no os preocupéis
de verdad
esto mirároslo
al final
ahora no
no es el momento
pero
si no
si eres antiguo
de alumno
mirad las mentorías
mensuales
anteriores
confío en una etapa 4
con a lo mejor
una entrada testada
y sin prisa
con señales
sin prisa
Axel
ya te digo yo
que no
no
va a haber prisa
no no no
no Axel
todo lo que tú
estás diciendo
me estás
describiendo
estrategias
para poner
en cuentas
ya
fondeadas
no en evaluaciones
es tal cual
el porfolio
que pondrías
en cualquier cuenta
que quieras
mantener
a lo largo del tiempo
no sé si lo he entendido
bien
entonces
usa el mismo robot
que creas en el wizard
que luego lo pasa
a la gestión de escalado
pero una de ellas
es la inversión
exactamente
Omar
entonces la idea
es abrir una compra
de diamante
y una mente
en FMS
así es
yo creo que lo ideal
es el copy
a la inversa
yo lo hice con robots
con la gestión de escalado
de inversa
y las señales
muchas veces
no coinciden
en el tiempo
directamente
una cuenta
no entra
exactamente
es uno de los riesgos
que hay
que también hemos visto
no sería mejor
aumentar el número
de robots
para que haya más operaciones
no porque también
el aumentar
hace que el día
que te está ganando
otros te están perdiendo
y eso no significa
que sea el mal robot
simplemente que es estadística
todo lo hacemos
con las preguntas
si hacemos exámenes
de una fase o de dos
dos fases
todos dos fases
para tener ese espacio
de margen
de poder caer
que es muy importante
¿Alguna vez han hablado
con respecto
a la limitante
que tenemos
de operar
MTL5
para los que estamos
en Estados Unidos
es una vez decidido
lo mejor imposible
operar MTL5
¿Por qué?
¿Eso es decidido
José Manuel?
¿Qué limitación tenéis?
¿Algún vídeo
creando una estrategia
simple
en la WIZAR
para M515M?
hay tutoriales
de algo WIZAR
de mentorías mensuales
hay una clase
seguro
que hicimos
tutorial completo
de algo WIZAR
mirároslo
también está ahí la clase
¿vale?
está prohibido MTL5
en Estados Unidos
y MTL4
¿Cómo que está prohibido
MTL5?
dirás
en algunos brokers
o sea
no creo que un país
prohíba
una plataforma
de trading
lo prohibirá
el broker
entiendo
creo que no es así
José Manuel
no sé
lo quiero poner en duda
hola
¿qué tal?
habla José Manuel
sí
dime
de hecho
sí
yo he visto
mucha dificultad
a la hora
de comprar
una cuenta
de fondeo
por ejemplo
en
Funding Pips
ofrece
la plataforma
MetaTrader5
pero a la hora
de hacer el pago
restringe
MetaTrader5
porque
yo estoy
en Estados Unidos
FTMO
puedo crear
una cuenta
en FTMO
aquí en Estados Unidos
pero a la hora
de hacer el pago
dice ahí
que la plataforma
de trading
no está permitida
en Estados Unidos
y así
muchas más
como
E8 Markets
y otras
por el estilo
que tienen buena reputación
pero
MetaTrader5
no lo he podido
por esa razón
no he podido
por decir así
ir como ya
tomando en cuenta
algunas compañías
como para decir
esta voy a utilizar
ya en el momento
que termine mi formación
y voy a crear
estrategias
MetaTrader5
para cuentas de fondeo
o por el estilo
Pues primera noticia
con alguna VPN
algo que lo ha dicho
ahora también
R.S. Fernando
con alguna VPN
a lo mejor
que no vean
que estén
en Estados Unidos
Puede ser
con una VPN
pero me van a pedir
como se llama
la verificación
a la hora
de conectar
cuenta bancaria
y cosas
por el estilo
Ah, dices
para realizar el pago
tu información de pago
Sí
o sea
para abrir la cuenta
en
cuenta de empresas
de fondeo
no hay problema
pero
siempre y cuando
yo no escoja
MetaTrader5
como mi plataforma
de trading
puedes coger
DX
no sé qué
no sé qué otras
hay también
pero MetaTrader5
Esto se tiene que arreglar
de alguna manera
de algún sistema
de pago
en la cual
pues
la tarjeta de crédito
o la cuenta bancaria
no sea de Estados Unidos
No sé si esto
tenéis la posibilidad
Bueno, no quiero
acaparar mucho
este tema ahora
pero
no lo desconocía
que los
gente
Ah, por el chat
ha habido gente
que decía
que no
que no estaba
prohibido
pero
si a ti te ha pasado
probablemente
en algunas empresas
que lo hayas experimentado
sí
Mira de probar
una de las cuatro
que yo te he dicho
a ver si ahí
tienes algún problema
o no
Ok
Sí, lo pregunté
en la clase anterior
con este
Sergi también
y sí
me decía que
había dificultades
al menos
en el conocimiento
de él decía
que lo teníamos
un tanto difícil
que necesitábamos
en Estados Unidos
pero
pensaba que
ustedes habían
este
trabajado
en alguna
solución
Yo sé que los CFD
están prohibidos
pero las cuentas de fondeo
no son CFD
porque es capital ficticio
por tanto
no entra en la regulación
podéis comprar
cuentas de fondeo
sin problema
podéis estar en dar
un estero
sin problema
porque es capital ficticio
todo lo que sea capital ficticio
sí que se permite
aunque sea CFD
Sí, eso sí
de hecho yo he comprado
Funding Pips
he comprado
E8 Markets
para trabajar
de forma manual
con TradeLocker
por ejemplo
la plataforma de trading
TradeLocker
pero específicamente
para decir
el portafolio
que estoy creando
conectarlo a MetaTrader 5
en estas plataformas
pues
por el momento
prueba en estas cuatro
que te he dicho
a ver si
alguna te va bien
Perfecto
Gracias
A ti
Cristian
Buenas noches
retomando el tema
de los objetivos
de la mentoría
de hoy
y si lo has comentado
en videos anteriores
de mentorías
yo estoy en el último grupo
finalizo ahorita
creo que en febrero
pero pues
para
tenerla clara
y es
actualmente
las estrategias
que se están desarrollando
están bajo el enfoque
de H1
porque es la estructura
que está
digamos que
definiéndose
en la metodología
la pregunta es
esto que estás
proponiendo ahora
de este modelo
de fondeo
aplicaría con esto mismo
o es desarrollar
otros modelos
para pasar
esa cuenta
de fondeo
pero igual
esto seguiría
andando
o sea
serían dos mundos
andando en paralelo
o en algún
momentico
se cruzan
esa es la duda
que me queda
con lo que estás
comentando hoy
Vale
los mundos
te refieres
evaluaciones de fondeo
y lo que estás aprendiendo
en el programa de mentoría
correcto
esto es únicamente
para pasar evaluaciones
de fondeo
únicamente
y lo que estás
tú aprendiendo
en el programa de mentoría
es para poner los sistemas
en cuentas
ya fondeadas
o bien
en cualquier
otro tipo de cuenta
que no sea una cuenta
de fondeo
ya sea una cuenta
de capital propia
en darwin
para crear tu tas récord
lo que sea que necesites
tener una consistencia
en los resultados
en evaluaciones
no necesitas tener consistencia
necesitas hacer un 7%
y punto
me queda claro
perfecto
muchas gracias
esa era
vale
de nada
Gonzalo
hola Ramón
mira
se me oye bien
¿no?
sí
mira
bueno
mi pregunta es simple
no me he metido
mucho de lleno
con algo wizard
pero
¿por qué se hacen
las estrategias
en algo wizard
y no se pueden crear
con un builder
por ejemplo?
las ventajas
y eso
porque
vas a dedicar
más tiempo
vale
para hacerlo
lo más simple posible
porque al final
el resultado
va a ser similar
vale
perfecto
gracias
voy a seguir
un poco
ahora el chat
por aquí dice
la edición abierta
puede tener acceso
a esta mentoría
sí
ahora
la última edición
que la primera vez
estáis aquí
os vamos a habilitar
a partir de mañana
todas las mentorías
mensuales
que hemos hecho
hasta la fecha
vale
por tanto
lo podéis ver todo
y es verdad
una de las cosas
también para el chico
de antes
de Estados Unidos
hay muchas de ellas
que te permiten
pagar con criptomonedas
y ahí sí que ya
no te piden
o sea
una verificación
de la cuenta bancaria
de este estilo
Ramón
buenas tardes
tienes un custom
project actualizado
de donde tiene
el último
donde está guardado
donde lo encuentro
aquí no hay custom projects
para esto
que he explicado
hoy
no sé
si te referías
a esto
el criptopunk
oficial
un poco bajo
hola
ahora sí
perdón
qué tal Ramón
un placer
a todos
un saludo
voy a hacer
una pregunta
de novato
en este tema
pregunto
porque
veo que has invertido
tiempo y dinero
en cuentas de fondeo
en pasar exámenes
y digo yo
sabiendo las reglas
de cada broker
o de cada cuenta
de fondeo
por así decirlo
seguro que me van a matar
con esta pregunta
pero
no hombre
mejor que pregunte
que no se pregunte
pero por qué no
hacerlo en cuentas demo
digo yo
para qué estar pagando
si primero podemos
testear en una cuenta demo
ver qué pasa
en diferentes situaciones
y una vez que vemos
que hay alta probabilidad
de pasar
esas reglas
o esas normas
pues se pone a trabajar
a ver qué tal
pasa
digo yo
para no gastar dinero
en exámenes
lo primero que hicimos
es abrirnos una cuenta demo
en Eftimo
que permitía
cuentas demo
y de hecho
esta la pasamos
¿qué pasa en entornos demos?
que
primero de todo
hay muchas reglas
o sea
todo el mundo conoce
las reglas del fondeo
que es
drawdown diario
drawdown máximo
máximo de trade
porcentaje
lo típico
pero lo que no
lo que no conocemos
es
ideas de trade
cosas reglas
más secundarias
que te saltan
o te vienen con una
o te van
o las vas aprendiendo
a medida que vas utilizando
esa empresa de fondeo
esto en demo
no lo conoces
y segundo
en demo tampoco
conoces el broker
donde tú vas a hacer
el trading ahí
bueno por tanto
nosotros en demo
vimos que el funcionamiento
funcionaba bien
pero sinceramente
yo ya reservé
un capital
obviamente
lo hacemos
con cuentas bajas
no lo hacemos
con cuentas de 100.000
pero
no no
entiendo
el concepto
o sea
por supuesto
mejor probar
sobre el terreno
que andar
inventando
un pavimento
pero
lo digo
como primera fase
de decir
bueno
primero veo
que más o menos
funciona
dentro de una cuenta
normal
yo mismo
voy monitoreando
las normas
que me autoimpongo
que fueron las
de una cuenta
de fondeo
y a partir de ahí
filtrando
las estrategias
que sean
digo bueno
las meto a trabajar
y lo que tú dices
pagando
un mínimo coste
producto mínimo viable
¿sabes?
yo hay dos motivos
uno al que te he explicado
que es la regla
que también dice
tema de las noticias
también es otro tema
que tal
de las noticias
uno es para probar
ya en el terreno
que realmente
vamos a jugar
de verdad
y el punto número dos
es por tiempo
si yo me pongo
unos meses
a trabajar
en cuentas demo
luego
es decir
es tiempo que pierdo
para daros
la información
ya no solo a vosotros
primero de todo
para yo saber
la respuesta
claro
al final
es coste de oportunidad
si tengo el capital
de permitir
entrar antes
y hacer la prueba
pues dedicar
3.000 euros
a comprar cuentas
con cuentas
de 15.000
20.000
10.000
ahora estamos con 10.000
pues decidí
hacer esa inversión
obtener los resultados
en medio año
un poco menos
si no hubiera estado más
es totalmente
es una pregunta
perfecta
o sea
ni nada
bien ti nada
bueno
gracias por
era más o menos
me imaginaba tu respuesta
pero
pero bueno
nada
mi caso
es como
bueno
primero por lo menos
ver cómo se funciona
algo
y luego
ya
totalmente
se tiene que hacer así
vale
gracias
un placer
igualmente
Luis Enrique
¿qué tal Ramón?
mira
te quería preguntar
una cosa
porque
te he dicho
el tema de los trades
porque yo he podido
crear robots
de 5 minutos
que arriesgan
un 1%
y ganan 3
¿vale?
pero el único problema
que estoy teniendo
es que no tengo
muchos trades
entonces no sé
si es que tú tienes
un KPI
diferente al que
nos ha dado
como el número
de trades
que estás utilizando
para que te abran
diariamente
o es el mismo KPI
que nos ha estado
enseñando en la
formación
¿cómo las estás creando?
esta de 5 minutos
con el Builder ¿no?
por eso es lo que he comentado
hazlo con el Algo Wizard
saca tú una estrategia
invéntate una estrategia
por internet
pero es que te lo puedo decir
un cruce de media
entre la media 5
y la de 10 periodos
a 5 minutos
te va a generar
mínimo un treto
y no podría utilizar
esa misma que tengo
de la que he creado
y poner en el Algo Wizard
ya pero
bueno pues
claro
es que a ver
el trading rentable
no es el trading
que opera cada día
y eso lo vais viendo
poco a poco
a medida que vais aprendiendo más
operar cada día
la obsesión
de operar cada día
es fundir el dinero
por tanto
las estrategias
no abren trades
cada día
las estrategias
buenas de verdad
¿por qué?
porque no cada día
el viento sopla
a tu favor
como debería
o no cada día
la estrategia
se da la señal
aunque sea 5 minutos
o 15
lo que sea
nosotros aquí
forzamos
queremos que hayan trades
cada día
pero no porque
la estrategia
sea rentable
sino para que
la estadística
de una cuenta
una a otra
llegue a take profit
a los 7%
tanto
tu afán
de ir
a
pasar una estrategia
que
presuntamente
es rentable
es para ganar dinero
a largo plazo
pasarla
a este marco
donde necesitamos
prisa
no tiene cabida
aunque sea
en 5 minutos
bueno
si tú mismo
me estás diciendo
que las que están saliendo
no abren cada día
pues
para mí
para mi punto de ver
el tema de las evaluaciones
de fondeo
que es
rápido
no tiene cabida
en mi visión
en tu visión
puede que sí
tú puedes
pasarla
a la wizard
puede
poder hacerlo
puedes
lo que pasa
es que si me dices
que te abre un trade
cada 4 días
pues a lo mejor
estarás
un mes y medio
en pasar una evaluación
vale
perfecto
como ya has dicho
que abriera
o sea
prácticamente
un trade por día
pues
pensé que tenías
algún KPI
o estabas
poniendo
algún tipo
de número
de trade
al año
o como pones
del 2023
no sé
o algo así
al 2025
entonces le añade
un número específico
de trade
para que te abra
sea un día
o sea caso
la estrategia
es que ponemos
la bobizar
si no capásemos
a lo mejor
te abrirían
23 al día
pero que al menos
sé que al menos
uno te lo abre
perfecto
gracias Ramón
a ti
vale
leo chance
una vez
paso la cuenta
de fondeo
que este
te dije
usas
sí
lo que estamos
platicando
en la mentoría
sí
tal cual es
las fondeadas
Ramón
a grandes rasgos
que activos
trabajaste
en las distintas etapas
forex
porque en cuentas
de fondeo
operar oro
operar
sobre todo índices
operar índices
es carísimo
los swaps
sobre todo
aunque no íbamos
con swaps
es verdad
bueno Iván
corrígeme
creo que oro también
no sé si van a estar
por aquí ya o no
forex principalmente
sí
en la fase 3
solo euro dólar
o sea
solo un activo
antes sí que poníamos oro
incluso
thousands
pero bueno
una mezcla de todo
es verdad
en fase 3
como que solo
hace falta
para dar un activo
el que tú
solo euro dólar
sí
Ramón
de todas las cuentas
fondeadas
que tienes operativas
cuál es la puntada
de número
que tienes
de las que conseguiste
operar de manual
de las que
logrado con robots
no no
yo hasta que no tengo
la metodología probada
que le estaba haciendo
con Iván
yo lo hago manual
todo lo que tengo
de hecho
mías propias
desde agosto
que no paso ninguna
ni tampoco compro ninguna
con las que tengo
ya me vale
ahora mismo tengo dos
tengo una tocadísima
o sea
tengo tres
una tocada
dos tengo
ahora mismo
tirando bien
y desde agosto
que no compré
fue la última que compré
mía personal de siempre
todo lo que he comprado
a partir de agosto
ha sido para el experimento
y la verdad
no he podido comprar
para mí
porque ya tenía
evaluaciones compradas
para experimentos
¿sabes?
y no quería operar
los mismos activos
bueno
un poco liada
también estaba conforme
también estaba muy conforme
con las dos que tengo
me ha ido muy bien
Axislet estos últimos meses
no me ha surgido
la necesidad
de querer comprarme más
pero ahora
cuando tengamos algo claro
aquí
saquemos algo claro
en la etapa 3
espero que sí
ahora ya sí
ya sí que
sacaré más
para mi nombre
claro
el cumpleaños
de la monica
testa
genial
gracias
me has preguntado algo
que no he entendido bien
no
pendejo
que me has respondido
a la
ah vale
vale
para ti
quieres rápido
pasar el test
de fondeo
mira
pues
una fase
digo
pues una fase
me gustaría pasarla
en menos de 10 días
en menos de 2 semanas
a menos eso
bastante menos
cuando les tomo pasar
la evaluación
en la fase 3
hemos empezado
ya
hace poco
o sea
esto ya
en la fase 3
os diré más
más información
en las próximas mentorías
no en la próxima
pero a lo mejor
dentro de dos
cuando hace una
estrategia
al wizard
le hace un backtest
que tienes en cuenta
es que el backtest
no me va a decir nada
básicamente
asegurarme
de que hayan trades
que hayan al mínimo
un trade por día
eso es lo mínimo
eso es lo único
no sé si tú
Iván
comprobar algo más
pero
eso es lo único
que buscamos
no no
que haga muchos
trades
o sea
sí
de hecho
no comprobo nada
solo hice una estrategia
muy al azar
o sea
cuando rompe
el máximo
de las últimas
5 velas
compro
y cuando rompe
el mínimo
vendo
y ya está
o sea
pero sí que la corrí
para ver que
en un año
igual me hacía
800 trades
o sea
el interés
acabará bastantos
cada día
puedo operar
aperturas de Wall Street
por ejemplo
estoy campeón también
la putada de esto
primero de todo
que hay mucho
slippage
a esas horas
te puede coincidir
con noticias
o no
yo lo evitaría
¿para qué?
si el objetivo
no es tener una estrategia rentable
¿cuántos robots
soléis poner
más o menos
por cuenta fondeo?
uno
ahora
digo en evaluación
estamos hablando
de evaluación
de la mentoría
de hoy
en vez de cruce de media
usar los citadores activos
lo que tú quieras
vale
Dante
aquí nos levanta la mano
hola a todos
¿qué tal?
buenas tardes
yo quería hacer una pregunta
con respecto
a
nosotros siempre hablamos
de estrategias
y
yo quería saber
si hay algún estudio
con respecto
al mercado
a los datos
¿a qué me refiero con esto?
¿qué posibilidad habría
de conocer
al que tengo enfrente
que serían los datos
que tengo
para decir
che
con esta caracterización
de mercado
la estrategia
que mejor se acomoda
sería esta
o esta o aquella
hacia el futuro
¿hay algún estudio
de esto
o no?
ya sé que lo tocamos
pero no sé
si tan directamente
no sé si me explico
bien en la pregunta
sí
pero lo que no entiendo
es
¿qué tiene que ver eso
con el material de hoy?
no, no
es una pregunta
es una pregunta aparte
no es con el material de hoy
vale
te lo voy a responder corto
porque realmente
no es materia de hoy
el Strategic One
cuando tú por ejemplo
crear estrategias tendenciales
ya por defecto
generalmente
siempre te van a sacar
perdona
activos tendenciales
ya automáticamente
o por lo general
te van a sacar
estrategias de breakouts
o continuación de tendencia
nosotros manualmente
no hacemos ningún estudio
no es necesario
creo que no es necesario
ese tiempo
con los resultados
que estamos teniendo
no, no
está muy bien
al final es ser prácticos
muchas gracias
sigo un momento en el chat
ahora bueno
habéis probado
la F óptima
diluida al 10%
no sé qué significa eso
si me lo puedes traducir
un poco en lenguaje
mal entendible
Ángel
no entiende ese concepto
Ramón
mira
sí bueno
yo he seguido
hace ya mucho tiempo
a un creador
de sistemas automáticos
y demás
y bueno
implementó
lo que es la F óptima
que es una forma
de generar
más rentabilidad
la F óptima
pura por así decirlo
es bastante agresiva
pero claro
diluida al 10%
digamos que ese 10%
cuando
es que
es como decir
se acierto
ha puesto
ese 10%
a tope
con la F óptima
y siempre preservo
ese 90%
de capital
cuando pierdo
solamente pierdo
digamos ese 10%
entonces estoy preservando
capital
es una forma
de decir
oye
aumentar también
las posibilidades
de ser más rentable
no sé
si nunca las he escuchado
es que de hecho
también
en lo que habíais
puesto vosotros
por ahí
de eso
también venía la F óptima
que es la F de Kelly
¿no?
o el sistema de Kelly
no sé
no te puedo contestar
Ángel
porque
no estoy complicando mucho
sí
yo al final
soy un chico
ya se me escapan
muchos conceptos
estadísticos
más avanzadores
lo que sea
pero yo al final
algo que tengo claro
es que
no me pienso
enredar por las ramas
si sé que algo
si puedo simplificar algo
y obtener
casi los mismos resultados
prefiero
hacer cosas simples
porque eso es más llevadero
a lo largo del tiempo
¿qué es lo que me ha pasado
ahora aquí?
lo hemos complicado tanto
que al final
hemos llegado
a un momento
en el cual hemos reducido
el pase de evaluaciones
de fondeo
porque
tanto esfuerzo
y tantas cosas avanzan
y tanto tal
para un posible 0,1
yo soy un poco así
soy un poco reduccionista
de esta forma
lo mismo simplificando
se llega más lejos
quizás
o igual
o un pasito menos
da igual
ya pero ahorras tiempo
claro
vale gracias
a ti
Raúl
¿por qué pasar
con problemas de fondeo
cuando puedes comprar cuentas
que no tienen fase de evaluación?
porque
te lo ha contestado Andrés
el Drodon
es demasiado ajustado
no vas a sacar
mucho dinero de ahí
al final queremos algo
relativamente holgado
para que podamos luego
sacar dinero
bueno en la fondeada
no entiendo muy bien
como si
os da igual
la estrategia es rentable o no
podéis estar seguros
de que con ella
vais a pasar la prueba
mírate Oscar
una mentoría mensual
en la cual explico
mi plan para pasar
evaluaciones de fondeo
que es como lo hacía yo
manualmente
bueno y lo sigo haciendo ahora
ahí explico
probabilidades
y el por qué
estadísticamente
sin tener una estrategia rentable
puedes pasarte
evaluaciones de fondeo
tienes que entender eso
una sesión solo de ello
¿podríamos ayudar
o colaborar a tener en cuenta
según vuestra visión?
o sea
¿cuál sería el mejor escenario
objetivo a buscar?
el escenario objetivo
a buscar
es pasarte
una de cada tres
evaluaciones
no
estar fondeado
no pasarte fases
pasar las dos fases
y en cada fase
como muy máximo
tirarte
siete días hábiles
eso es el escenario ideal
y tener un ratio
del
33% superior
no digo de fase 1
a fase 2
digo de fase 1
a estar fondeando
directamente
eso es el escenario ideal
las que no tienen fase
de evaluación
por lo que no te permiten
Arturo
venga
vamos con las últimas
preguntas
si no lo voy a hacer
muy tarde aquí
si no
¿Arturo?
no te oí
creo que no te oímos
bueno Arturo
no te oímos
te tengo que pasar
perdón
ya me escuchas
ahora sí
discúlpame
tuve que cambiar
de micrófono
bueno
la pregunta
viene con respecto
a la última
mentoría
del custom project
que nosotros
cargamos
toda la configuración
pues de
de Ramón
y la H
yo lo hice
con la R de Ramón
y
mi pregunta es
en los resultados
en lo último
de ese final
y de MQ4
salen diferentes
entonces digamos
una estrategia
de ese final
me sale
positiva
y en el
MQ4
sale
como si la estrategia
no fuera
rentable
no sé
si hay algo
malo ahí
o
no
Arturo
me sabe mal
cortarte
pero
mejor
lánzalo
en tu grupo
esto
porque
no es tema
de hoy
ahora mismo
me ha empezado
a decir cosas
que ya me he perdido
un poco
mejor
lánzalo
con pantallazos
en tu grupo
de Discord
y te asistirán
ahí
aunque sí
sino que ya
te lo preguntaba
así rápidamente
porque
ya lo había
preguntado
en el grupo
pero pues
todavía no
he conseguido
como una respuesta
entonces pues
no sé
por eso
te lo preguntaba
es que no te puedo
así a bote pronto
no te sabría
dar una respuesta
o sea
tendría que ver
más detalladamente
esa
por eso
vuelvo a hacer énfasis
vuelvo a reformarlo
de otra manera
o si hay alguna respuesta
que no te ha
no te ha encajado
decirle
oye esta respuesta
no me ha encajado
o no lo he terminado
de ver
porque
liso
muchas gracias
Ramón
vale
y lo siento
Arturo
podría repetir
las empresas
que estoy utilizando
hoy
The Trading Pit
The Five First
Funded Nets
y Wall Street Funded
proyectos de
seguir como
el último semestre
ya los iré
ya los iré diciendo
tengo que marchar
un saludo
vale
mira José Carlos
dice menciona ley
te echará un
un cable
vale Arturo
creo que hemos terminado
todas las preguntas
había un tema
que había dejado
como tema secundario
que siempre tengo
que es
una de copy trading
mirad
la de copy trading
como que aún no está lanzado
es decir
os diré un poco
la idea que tengo
en
en SymbolStats
es crear
un
a ver un momento
es crear un apartado
donde podamos subir
Expert Advisor
vale
nosotros ya tenemos
unos cuantos
tenemos un Expert Advisor
que te evita noticias
que
que esto no hemos subido
aún para vosotros
algunos también
que tenemos
recopilados
que hemos recopilado
a lo largo de estos tiempos
ya sea por internet
y que lo hayamos pasado
por nuestra supervisión
o incluso hechos
por alumnos nuestros
que a día de hoy
pues están en
en un canal
de desarrolladores
que muy poca gente
entra
porque es verdad
que se hablan
de cosas muy avanzadas
pues me gustaría
como estanderezarlos
para que todo el mundo
los pueda utilizar
hay un repositorio común
de Expert Advisor
y
y lo tengas ahí
en SymbolStat
para que los pague descargado
vale
ahora recientemente
hemos desarrollado
uno de copy trading
para poder replicar
trades
independientemente
lo que haga la segunda cuenta
la primera la que manda
se abre un trade
en la otra se abre también
vale
que a veces a lo mejor
pues por indicadores
o por datos
no se ejecuta ese segundo trade
e incurrimos en que no podemos
hacer la inversa
os quería hacer una demo
pero realmente
os lo haré en otro momento
cuando tengamos
en otra mentoria mensual
pero básicamente
os quería enseñar
como en un MetaTrader
abrir una operación
y se abre la otra
automáticamente
nada más
no hay mucho más truco
ahí detrás
vale
pero lo tenía ahí
como enseñarlos
como tutorial
por si
quedábamos cortos
de tiempo
en la mentoria mensual
pero
llevamos una hora y media
creo que la gente
que estamos en España
pues
muchos de vosotros
queréis ir a cenar ya
así que
así que nada
esto lo dejaremos
cuando lo tengamos desarrollado
en esa pantalla
ya os la presentaré
con todos los expert advisors
pero que sepáis
que estamos en ello
vale
y nada
ir mejorando poco a poco
ya sabéis que siempre
intento venir con cosas nuevas
o con avances de cosas
que de proyectos
un poco más
más largos
tengo
me han preguntado
tengo en la cabeza
varios proyectos
varias movidas
que me quiero meter
nuevas en 2026
ya os lo iré contando
vale
porque a lo mejor
deciré algunas que no
siempre al final
es también un poco
dar
centrar el foco
en lo que realmente sabes
que le podrás dedicar
un tiempo de calidad
y nada
antes de irnos
pues
desearos
un feliz año 2026
los que llevéis
haciendo trading
este año 2025
pues quedan
dos días de trading
que os vaya muy bien
a mí me ha ido muy mal
los últimos dos tres días
no muy mal no
pero me he comido
unos stop-loss
que dices tú
siempre dices tú
joder
para qué los tengo
para qué los tengo abiertos
y yo mismo me respondo
y dices
Ramón tío
has trabajado sistemas
con una estrategia
que incluye
todos los días
del año hábiles
no tienes ningún motivo
de por qué desconectar
los sistemas
y esto
también os lo digo
a todos vosotros
no desconectes los sistemas
salvo que sean
un objetivo cortoplacista
tipo
en HCL
quiero pasar la fase
de un 7%
llego a un 7%
corta
porque no necesitas
operar más
pero en Darwinets
en HCL
yo ya que estoy en un millón
que ahí ya no hay límite
o en otros sitios
pues con cuentas ya fondeadas
pues dices
no lo desconectéis nunca
porque a largo plazo
siempre van a salir
beneficiosos
sin cortarlo
¿vale?
así que nada
muchas felicitaciones
veo en el chat
de verdad
pasadlo bien
estos
este final de año
principio de año
no os emborrachéis mucho
lo justo
y
y nada
que paséis un tiempo de calidad
que al final es lo que todo el mundo
está buscando
tener más tiempo de calidad
con los vuestros
y con
vuestros familiares
amigos
y familia cercana
así que feliz año
mucho éxito en 2026
que
que tengáis más retiros
y
y la rentabilidad
al menos sea
para los que no habéis tenido
un positivo
que sean positivo
y para los que tenéis un positivo
pues
que sigáis siendo positivos
da igual
si en el que viene
marcáis
un profit menor al de este año
o similar
realmente si vais marcando
ange tras año
profit
profit en verde
pues eso que suma
para vuestro currículum
¿vale?
igualmente Ramón
venga felices fiestas
y
y profit
¿no?
y buenos profit
chao igualmente
chao a todos
chao
gracias Ramón
feliz año
muchísimas gracias
feliz año a todos